well I guess romance isn't dead let us
know in the comments how you would
propose to your sex doll and that's a
cup great job everybody
especially Ryan thank you your normal
bad okay yes I know Nate might be away
for a while so let me know if you have
any ideas for a replacement host that's
ominous do you think he's dying he's
always so sick probably arthritis wait
what
these jobs up for grabs it's like I
could own you guys I found if any
[Music]
hey crazy running to you here in my
office totally right listen I think we
both are in agreement that I should be
the one who gets Nate's job why is that
because I Jordan Mendoza I'm a cultural
icon did you know I'm dating Jack
Nicholson's niece you oh well not
exactly
I have been catfishing her for weeks as
Logan Paul so I'm close by the way I'm
gonna need to be reimbursed for facial
reconstructive surgery yeah no I see the
watercooler
classic place for an office conversation
you know I've got a little experience
leading conversations if you know what I
mean
I'm an expert climate immigration oil
well typically on our pop culture show
we avoid politics but if you have big
ideas let's talk about them right now
right right now yeah right now sure in
climate is good immigration very good
oil bad gun
stupid don't even know you have this in
your office you know what I believe I
misunderstood the assignment please
allow me just the kind of leadership we
can expect from me that was my father's
statement so when does that pay bump
kick in because I'm kind of going
through a bit of a lawsuit see I took a
credit card from a guy who I hooked up
with but I let him do anal you know and
plus I'm not responsible I was drunk I
know what's in that cup water that
happens to smell like alcohols
so let's share Social Security numbers
you go first
please go fine down here step into my
office this is my office then why am i
under your desk dummy look I know you
want a gun and I'm telling you I can do
it clean no witnesses oh my god I do not
want Nate dead really then why did I
think you did I have no idea huh anyway
your feet stink and I love it thank you
all for bombarding me but it turns out
Nate will not be leaving after all whoa
wait all the writers bro oh you could do
it never is you know I once hooked up
with a guy who had arthritis still get
flare-ups I think the horse that kicked
me had arthritis that's life one with
the mouth none of you know what
arthritis is look I wasn't sick I was
gone because I thought that I was up for
a job and Logan Paul squad would have
been cool but it turns out it was just
an impostor so it looks like I'm stuck
here with you morons but that's so weird
don't give up though you can definitely
keep demoing that guy money and I don't
know I've already lost like $4,000 wait
how did you know I'd then motive money
shut up
Jordan
[Music]
you